So Donald Trump has now gone about a month
without taking questions from reporters. He's
been almost completely missing from the public
eye. And last Friday, he finally did a so-called
press conference. Now I say so-called because
he could have really prerecorded it and just
played a video. He took no questions. There
was no interaction whatsoever with the press
that was actually in the room. The event was
supposed to be about his work on prescription
drug prices. And Trump somehow managed to
hold it together for the first few minutes
and then he just couldn't. And you can see him
trying to resist. But in the middle of reading
from his notes about prescription drugs, he goes
off script and he blurts out that he actually won
the election. Now, as a reminder, he didn't win
the election. He lost by quite a bit. The entire
event goes completely off the rails from there.
Let's look at it. Here is Donald Trump midsentence
about big pharma running ads against him, and
he just loses it and blurts out that he won.
This is not an easy thing to do. Big Pharma ran
millions of dollars of negative advertisements
against me during the campaign, which I won,
by the way. But, you know, we'll find that out.
Almost 74 million votes. We had big pharma
against us. We had the media against us. We had
big tech against us. We had a lot of dishonesty
against us. But Big Pharma alone ran millions and
millions of dollars in ads. In fact, I looked
at it. I said, who is it? They said, I won.
By the way. I had dishonesty against me.
It's truly embarrassing at this point. It's
actually been embarrassing a really long time.
He just cannot control himself. I won, guys. I
won. Really. I did. Believe me, it's it's to some
degree, like he's trying to convince himself that
he won. A few other strange moments here is Donald
Trump saying he's been loyal to special interests.
I don't know if this is a Freudian slip or if
Donald Trump thinks it means something different
than what we think it means to say
you've been loyal to special interests.
I don't know. But take a listen to this.
Lawyers, lobbyists and bought and paid for
politicians. But I've been loyal to the special
interests. I've been loyal to our patients.
Yeah. So it's unclear if Donald Trump knows what
that means or understands that typically you
don't want to admit to being all about the special
interests loyal to special interests in politics.
But it's Trump, you know, it could be a Freudian
slip. He might not understand what it means.
He might be honest. He might be glad about being
loyal to special interests. I don't know. Trump
then also just can't get away from the me, me,
me, saying we're only this close to vaccines
because of him. And in saying this, he instead
of saying Pfizer, the pharmaceutical company,
he says Pfizer, which is something else
altogether, the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Act. It's just a mess.
I was put here to do a job
and Pfizer and others were way ahead on vaccines.
You wouldn't have a vaccine if it weren't for me
for another four years because FDA would
have never been able to do what they did.
Now, in fact, the FDA hasn't really done anything
yet on vaccines. I hope people understand this.
Private companies and universities have been
developing vaccines. The FDA in a couple of
weeks is going to meet along with some independent
panels and they will look at the data from these
companies, Pfizer, Biogen, Tech Moderna, Oxford.
AstraZeneca is moving ahead very quickly and they
will decide in December whether these vaccines
should get emergency use, as we've already
discussed. So this is weird and it's even getting
stranger and stranger as it goes on. Donald Trump
remaining very conspiratorial, suggesting that
news of a coronavirus vaccine receiving approval
after the election was part of the conspiracy to
bring him down, that they could have announced
this before the election, but it might have helped
him. They didn't want to help him, so they waited.
Take a look at their vaccine. In other
words, not come out with a vaccine
until just after the election. That's because of
what I did with favored nations and these other
elements instead of their original plan
to assess the data in October. So they
were going to come out in October, but they
decided to delay it because of what I'm doing,
which is fine with me because frankly. This
is just a very big thing, a very big thing,
what I'm doing here, I don't know
if anyone's going to appreciate it.
These people can't even believe it, Alex. Even
you can't believe it, can you? Look at you.
So they waited and waited and waited and they
thought they'd come out with it a few days after
the election and it would have probably had
an impact. Who knows? Maybe it wouldn't have.
So Donald Trump, of course, as always, the
ultimate victim, complaining that he doesn't get
appreciation. No one has been treated less fairly
than Donald Trump in the world, in the history of
the world, of any president in history, if you
believe his perspective. And he almost kind of
back candidly admits that he lost, saying if the
vaccine had been approved before the election,
I might have won. But of course, he's also trying
to convince us that he did win. So he has to back
up and say, well, maybe it would maybe it wouldn't
have had an impact. And then lastly, as Seema
Verma wraps up, she's just horrible. She's been a
part of Donald Trump's coronavirus task force for
a while after Sima Verma wraps up, Donald Trump
just kind of slowly slinking off after waving to
someone in the audience without even saying
the press briefing is over on a microphone,
naturally not taking a single question.
Success over the last four years is a testimony
to that mentality. Thank you.
Thank you. So. Thank you.
The election was three weeks ago. Joe Biden has
selected a treasury secretary who he says he will
tell us sometime around Thanksgiving. He selected
a chief of staff. He selected a secretary of
state, a national security adviser, an ambassador
to the United Nations. Joe Biden has created and
has started meeting with a coronavirus task force.
And he's been speaking to governors about what are
we going to do in terms of masks, in terms of the
virus, in terms of all of this. And meanwhile,
Donald Trump and his administration still have
not even acknowledged, hey, we had an election,
you aren't going to be president anymore in
eight and a half weeks. They still have not
acknowledged that. Truly bizarre times that we are
living through. I am very much looking forward to,
as I said earlier in our discussion about foreign
policy and Donald Trump, Joe Biden rather choosing
his secretary of state, I really am looking
forward to getting back to more substantive
policy discussion once we can get rid of this
menace and we are eight and a half weeks from it.